thank you so much for having me again i
was excited to see that it was going to
be you
yeah this uh
we have all been talking about this show
since we watched it
and has anyone decided if that's in a
good way or a bad way yet
it's insane in like the best way
possible so i i very much appreciate
just how absolutely batshit crazy the
show is
um but it was funny because i think i
was the first person that
watched the whole season so i was like
just waiting for somebody to like have a
conversation with him
and uh yeah so
i mean that's the thing about the show
that i i
you know that kind of like we were all
joking when we were making it nick and
lenora and i like
especially shooting some of those
some of the crazier scenes
you know like and matt sobel who
directed the fourth episode like when we
did that crazy sex scene
we were just like i mean it's hard to
think people won't want to talk about
this whether or not they like it you
know it's just so
it's i know the feeling of feeling like
because i spent that i was i read that
scene in in uh
probably
it was like october of 2019
so like i've been thinking about it
since then and i've been like i am so
curious what people are going to think
of this so i'm very happy i'm very happy
yeah and it was funny because i remember
we briefly talked about it when i spoke
to you for the last season of agents of
shield and i had no idea so
i'm sorry that's the thing because i
think like i i don't think you know
anyone
did or does kind of until you see it i
think that you have to kind of like and
i really i've it's it's been cool
because you know obviously it's not even
properly come out until today but it
does seem like
people are appreciating
that it's unique and that it's a big
swing
and i and that is immediately you know
like nick all of nick's work this is my
third uh thing with nick and tosca and
all of his work is always like that to
me and i think there's like a bravery
and a brilliance in that
so i'm it's very cool to that that other
people respond to it because it's wild
and like you don't know you really don't
know
yeah and you definitely can't half-ass
it with a show like this it just would
never have worked
yeah that's and and luckily
the cool thing about that i think that's
so true is like when you
when you have catherine keener and rosa
and eric and manny
and hannah levine and you know all these
people like there's such great actors
that they can like you know
keep it in some sense of realism even
though it's like obviously the furthest
thing from it so it's a very
it's it's yeah it's a tight rope
well before we get further into episode
four going back to the beginning
how much were you told about this what
did they tell you like what did nick say
when he mentioned this project
he so um you know we had worked on
channel zero together and i
knew uh you know he he's so distinct so
i i knew when this came around
that it would be
something really different and something
exciting and um
but i didn't that's the cool thing about
like cracking a nick and tosca script i
think or or a book or a short story is
like you it always i think ends in a way
that's going to i remember when he first
pitched me my character arc on channel
zero i consider myself a fairly
intelligent you know
story mind and like i can usually
somewhat predict where things are going
i remember the first time he told me
that like my jaw dropped so it was a
very cool um
you know to get i didn't know exactly
what to what to expect and then when i
knew i was doing it and him and i were
talking about it
he was like let me send you the first uh
five episodes that those scripts are
ready you can read them and see what you
think
i read them and like
yeah i mean you know not to jump right
back into the fourth episode but like
when i read that script i was like
i got nervous i was like i've never done
i've never done anything like this i've
never seen anything like this like this
is really
crazy and and i was very nervous at
first and then when i got over that it
was exciting i mean how many times you
get to do a scene that you feel like has
never really been done before
so you know
there's some excitement to it or have a
relationship where all of a sudden the
girl is throwing up kittens and he just
keeps showing back up
like that would be the first thing to
get as far away as possible
that's that's something that i actually
you know i i think that like
we stumbled into
with roy in general
was something that like
there there had to be kind of a
magnetism about her and sort of
um a sweetness that it brings out in him
that he doesn't normally feel for people
because that was the only way it could
justify in my mind exactly what you're
saying why does he keep coming back
to this like
kitten vomiting you know
like
clearly drugged out like insane girl
that has trouble following her around i
think it's like
i really feel like rosa and i would talk
about sometimes in my mind it feels like
um it's a bit of like their story is a
bit of a romeo and juliet
like they would have been a perfect pair
and could have been you know the perfect
ones for each other but this curse
changed things so that you know it was
it was a it was an interesting challenge
to try and justify that and and
hopefully we hopefully we made some
sense of it i mean in his defense it is
a bit it's an escalation it's not like
it's all happening at one time but still
like at some point you would think he'd
be like okay this is the fifth kitten
i've seen you throw up i'm out of here
and he tries i mean he try he does his
best to get away from her and to tell
her i can't see you anymore like and i
can't i can't keep doing this and it's
you know it's like it's also something
that is always was interesting and
and
fun to me is it's you know it's the
power of like that kind of
insane having feelings for someone it's
like you look past the kitten throwing
up because you're like ah she'll she'll
be cool she'll be cool she'll figure it
out
with all of the craziness and all of
these wild like what the [ __ ] moments
was there anything that you were scared
about being actually able to pull off or
was it all just excitement and it was up
to nick to figure out how to do it
it was uh
getting
my head
pulled off
was
that was uh challenging and um and i
just it was a very it was very funny
because like everyone
everyone was um
covered in these like white hazmat suits
because there was so much blood
everywhere that when we were doing those
um
[Music]
we were doing those scenes and it was
very funny because like all there was
kind of a giddiness
on set about it and everyone was like
yeah we're pulling his head off it was
hard not to feel weird about it at a
certain point because like 50 people
were like sitting around like this is it
this is something we're gonna rip his
head clean off off off and then they're
gonna eat what's left of it it's kind of
like oh my god
why is everyone so happy about this but
it was um and it was like a legit it was
it was very tough to pull off
logistically like it was a lot of
different um angles and a lot of
different
you know trying to like then there was a
puppet that was involved and you know so
there was like a lot of different so
that was a very technically challenging
and that scene in general just with boro
and lisa and
and roy kind of in that standoff with
all the zombies around and you know code
is there and all that stuff like that
was just such a gargantuan scene to do
it took like two or three days
but um yeah so that was a technical one
that i and i remember the first time i
heard and saw a storyboard
for when uh roy gets literally pulled
apart by these zombies
and um
i was kind of like whoa i mean that's
crazy but i'm into that the the sex
scene scared me more i was like this is
this feels more frightening
but um
and it was also you know like
i remember the first time i saw the
jaguar demon the the thing that like
moves like that like and it was
horrifying in real life like it did not
look any less crazy so that was another
one that was a fun it was a fun
challenge
yeah i was curious with that
scene with them removing your head which
you know at least they've reattached
again properly
um i was
you know wondering how much of that was
done with makeup and prosthetics and
things that were there how much was cgi
how much was a puppet like i was just
wondering like how
that would have been practical
because it looks really good yeah i'm
glad i'm glad it's it's it was almost
all practical it was like a lot of
um
like
reverse shots and like doing things
backwards and like and i had to stand
there dying with blood coming down my
neck for like a full minute like several
times and we had to change me out
because i was so much such an
unbelievable amount of blood
but um
it was it was really it was cool too
because like i have such a affinity for
practical effects
and obviously grew up on that so that
was to get to not have to be reliant on
cg for sequences like that and and the
kittens like the kittens to me the fact
that those are practical
is such it makes the com it makes all
the difference in the world because they
look amazing they look so
cool and like and they were like you
know i don't want to give it away but
like they're on my you know they're
being puppeted and like it's it's just a
very
i was so i loved all the practical
especially for such a 90s vibe it really
i think it fits tonally
yeah i mean it sounds weird to say that
like the scene of your head being ripped
off is done well but
it was and what was it like for you to
watch that the first time like the
finished scene
the first time i saw it it was not like
colored and kind of like it wasn't
completely completely done and there was
like you know i think that there is like
a little bit of cg cleanup in in some of
the in some of the shots and that stuff
hadn't gotten done yet but when i have
seen it i mean
i was like i definitely watched it and
was like i gotta warn
my mom and dad about this
because i they
if they're gonna watch this i think it's
unfair to let this sneak up on them
because it does look incredibly real so
that's you know and and to to nick you
know it's it's difficult to pull that
off it's difficult to get and and there
was um
i had to sit
you know as as many people do but i had
to sit under just like hours and hours
of silicone and like breathing through
straws
to get you know that the aphasia and it
was it was up to my chest so it was like
to get my whole bust
and then uh
rip it clean off and start eating out of
it so
well when it came to doing that sex
scene what were the conversations and
discussions like when it came to that
like how
because there hadn't been um you haven't
read anything like that nothing's been
done like that like how how were those
conversations about what it would be how
it would be conveyed
um we talked about
how i talked to nick and matt
about matt sobel directed that one and
uh nick i talked to them about
how i wanted it to be the most [ __ ] up
version of two people falling in love
that i've ever seen
like them like the moment that they fall
in love is this moment
and
they were both into that and they both
really you know matt had the idea that i
love that um the whole show is
uh there's there's no handheld shots in
the show except for that scene there's
uh when it when it goes to her coming
off the bed it turns into a handheld
shot and stays in one
in one take for a lot of it
and i think that that lends it such an
incredible like literally breaking out
of
the kind of rhythm of like her life and
the show and his life and like they
actually kind of like
i i in my mind really fall in love with
each other in this crazy moment and i
think he's like that we played with like
how confused is he how turned on is he
what is it that he's going through
because he does it so what's the level
of comfort but and we tried to you know
find a balance where it was kind of like
interesting because i it felt like she
she
you know rose is such a powerful
performer like it was it when it
happened it just kind of took on its own
life and i remember the last take that
we did which is the one that's in the
show nick and matt running in and being
like you know we got it like that was
that was crazy and and it was you know
like
the first time i saw it the first time i
saw the
the hole the side hole i it was like it
was crazy she also rosa played a mean
joke on me that she goes check it out
and she goes touch it and i lean my hand
in and she goes wow and it really
freaked me out and she was obviously
messing with me but it was re it was it
scared the [ __ ] out of me because i was
like the thing just made me nervous
but it was you know and it was like when
we were doing it i also remember there's
a shot where like it goes up to my
forearm
and i remember when we were doing that
i was like doing it
two it was at that point it was a
mannequin like it wasn't her anymore
most of it is her but then at just that
point it's not
and i remember like looking at it and it
was and i was like i this is horrible
i mean i'm doing it i see how fake it is
and it's freaking me out like when this
is
and when it's all cut together and real
i mean like you know it is almost
unbearable but hopefully you know if
it's your thing cinematically it's in
it's in a good way i mean it's it's in
that car accident like you know
hopefully the stories earned it
and so you know like when it's when it
gets to that point you kind of can't
take your eyes off it i mean or you can
very much take your eyes off it and you
turn the show off forever one of those
two things yeah it definitely cannot
exist in any other show
and i was just like you know he he's
very accepting of this like he doesn't
question it he just like
is very accepting of this because it's
also like because i think that there's
such a beautiful moment of connection
between the two of them before it
happens you know i think that to me it's
the most vulnerable and beautiful
moment um that lisa has in terms of like
her personal life and her pathos is like
that monologue that she has about her
mother beckoning her in through this
trap door and roy
you know
he's clearly relates to that and has
some conflicting feelings in past of his
own that you know feels like that
conjures up so it feels like it feels to
me always like the reason that that
scene can exist in such an insane way is
because there is this and i
you know give so much credit to nick and
lenore for this that there is this real
moment of connection and this real
identification between the two
characters of like oh i see you
and i think you see me back
and it then leads to
you know okay that's your thing i guess
that's your thing i don't know
was it weirder to watch that scene or to
watch your own head being ripped off
definitely that scene
and the head ripped off was like oh yeah
it's crazy but like
that's sexy like it's it's it's it's
bananas i mean and i and i you know i'm
very proud to have done it even though i
was very afraid to do it
yeah i mean anytime anybody pulls
something off that you've never seen
before could never imagine and probably
will never see again definitely needs a
kudos
i appreciate that because i that's
that's how i feel and it takes it takes
um
it takes uh some bravery to be able to
to be able to do that uh you know for
nick and lenore
yeah i'm probably more afraid of whoever
actually put it on paper but yeah yeah
you should
i was just i was just told what to do
they just told me they told me i was
like y'all are sick
what the hell is wrong with you
well what was it like to work with rosa
throughout this because there are so
many crazy things that happen and the
emotions of this are often very
heightened
so
what was it like to go through that with
her how is she as a scene partner
she's you know i mean rose is a super
talented actor and
she
i adm you know her and i both share a
deep love for um
acting and and film and and the history
of both of those things and
she brings
so much to every scene and it's and i
you know it is incredibly difficult
when you are when you have a role like
hers where you're in every scene
and you have so much to do all the time
and you have such
heightened and surreal elements that you
have to pull off it's a very very
difficult job
and i think that you know she showed up
ready to do it every single day which
in in and of itself takes uh you know
a kudos
but um
she also
is she is uh she's a bit of a
perfectionist and driven you know
constantly to get the best thing and i
feel the same way so it it made for um
both of us being
always really determined to get the most
effective and interesting and different
you know um
terms of storytelling into into a given
scene but um you know i really
she she was amazing and i i was uh i was
blown away by i feel like it's in a show
like that it is very dependent on
that performer whoever it is
to really show up in the most
you know the like for instance one of my
favorite
moments in the series is when she is the
the end of the first episode when she
throws up the cat for the first time
like that to me is like
such a amazing and
uh
beautifully performed you know like and
really vulnerable and
you know and and and another another
scene that i love of her so much is when
she comes to me and she's tripping on on
the poison and we have to have we have
to have sex again you know in order for
the blood magic to work
yeah this show
and uh
and it's funny because like when she was
doing that scene she was cracking me up
because she's she's so real in someone
that's like tweaking out on drugs but
kind of has a mission that they need to
do
and i you know i i feel like the
craziest moments work because of her
performance and that you know
it it needed it and she delivered so
she i think she did an excellent job
yeah and catherine keener too as the
other anchor because like that character
could have been
it could have just gone so wrong in so
many ways
and i think she's just brilliant in that
role
i always used to we would i would joke
whenever i would see her i was like i
love that her she's like homeless
couture yeah she's like the mo she's
like the craziest like
trash pile of the highest fashion and
and it makes you know she she too i mean
catherine is so she's been an idol of
mine
for a long long time so when i was
i was i was so excited that i got to
work with her because i was just like
you're katherine keener i mean like come
on like you know and she and what was
cool about her is she just
she showed up so
uh
with so much um um
i just learned so much watching her come
to work all the time because she's so
good but she's so alive and so you know
just exactly in the moment and she's so
funny so so funny so like i you know i
was like there were scenes where i was
like i'm pretty good at not laughing in
scenes and like
she sometimes i'd just be like ah
like that's because it was just she's
bored and she would just you know scream
i'm borrow all the time so it's like
yeah of course yeah it takes crazy cat
lady to a whole new level sure does yeah
yeah
i haven't thought about that oh yeah
yeah kind of frightening i will never
look at that the same again yeah
you've been doing such a
wide variety of projects from agents of
shield to this to hacks i mean like you
couldn't get three more different shows
if you tried is any of that intentional
are you enjoying that is it weird to be
so like completely all over the map
it's it's a little bit intentional it's
uh you know it's also luck i mean like
because you never real you do your best
to to try and find
interesting stuff to do but like you
know it doesn't always work out and like
you never
whether you get to do the thing you
thought was interesting or whether you
do the thing it's interesting and it
didn't turn out the way that you hoped
or thought it would
but you know
shield obviously
you know is is um
feels like home you know that is like
such a that was such a long
it was such a big part of my life
and then you know
to get to then
uh cherry flavor i actually shot cherry
flavor first and then hacked after that
you know deke on shield has such a
wonderful variety of kind of uh being
the goof but also
showing up when he needs to and being
kind of uh
anti-hero in certain in certain respects
and then you know like getting to do
cherry which was like so
no holds barred like you know everything
was on the table like you know
kind of like where shield felt like such
a marvel tried and true
you know we know this works kind of like
you know this is our playground cherry
flavor we were you know completely
building a new playground that had never
been built before and this and the slide
has like weird spikes on it but
but you know like it was
it was such a you know that that was so
liberating because it was such an
inverted experience um from shield and
it you know it feels like it feels like
different cuisine you know like pizza
and sushi it's like
it's it's such a fun thing to be able to
bury that up and then going to hacks
like
paul
called me
and asked me to do the table read for
for that part and i immediately fell in
love with it because i was like this is
this is paul rudd in the first act of a
rom-com except he kills himself like
it's such a that's so amazing like it's
so weird and so like it to find humor
and and humanity in that
was like such a completely different you
know um style and and and
just to keep the same analogy playground
but uh that one that ended where he died
but you know it was
it's a very um
it's something that i hope to to
continue to do because i'm interested in
all of those things what i'm noticing
about myself is that like i feel like
whatever i've just done i kind of want
to do something
totally different and opposite than that
it's that's kind of what seems to be the
and it it feels like it might happen
again we'll see but uh it's
so i i you know i felt like um
roy and george were so
at least trying you know it's funny to
try and call either of those things
naturalism because they're ultimately
very
crazy but like much more you know kind
of like a for cherry flavor like for
instance playing roy justin thoreau in
mulholland drive was a huge inspiration
for me like kind of that him serving
that um
function in the story of kind of this
like getting
caught up all in it but not knowing
exactly what's going on but kind of
going with it but like you know and
being a good probably a fairly good
person maybe they're like you know maybe
a bad person that gets caught up in all
of this like so i think that there's
like kind of a um
there's an understatement hopefully that
i was trying to go for i think in both
of those because i was trying to like
undercut the bigger things that were
going on
so it feels kind of like i'm now right
now kind of more like wanting to do
something a bit more heightened and a
bit more uh crazy like as as as its own
character yeah i was like where do we go
from here yeah people hear a musical
like what
i mean
i
i can't talk about it but if i but if
the thing i hope it is then um i i think
i'll we'll have another conversation
about it
[Music]
yeah because this definitely i mean i'm
glad that people are seeing it now
because i'm i'm having more and more
conversations about it now but this is
certainly one of those things that you
watch and you're like oh my god i have
to talk to somebody right now
i'm so i'm so happy because that is kind
of you know with a show like this that's
kind of i think that's what we were
always hoping for is something that
would just be engaging enough to get
people excited and want to talk about it
and you know because i that's all of my
favorite stuff that's what happens you
know it's like it's gets you one it
makes you wanna i just finished i just
finished the second season of dave and
like i just think it's such a fantastic
show and i'm like oh my god has anybody
seen this i gotta talk about it
so i i know the feeling and it's uh it's
a i'm honored uh i'm honored that you
that you feel that way
yeah because it is wild and and it is
definitely a show that you want to talk
about which you know i just
it shouldn't work and somehow you all
managed to pull it off and i don't know
how because it really shouldn't work but
it does
that's i think that's a fair description
and and nick and lenore would not argue
with you and i yeah it's like
but i think that that's kind of what's
exciting too is you know the mulholland
drive
aspect of things like that
you know obviously the history of it
with uh him shooting it you know as a
pilot and then just like adding on the
rest it's like that shouldn't work that
is like that shouldn't yield one of the
best movies
in my humble opinion ever made but like
you know for some reason it's j it's
just a weird enough and just enough of a
of an attempt at something different
that it it makes something cool and i
hope that's what we kind of pulled off
with this
yeah and i have to say i love small and
drive too i still am not entirely sure i
fully know what it was about but i love
it because i love so exciting i love
david lynch twin peaks will for always
always and forever be my favorite show
even though i still don't fully
understand it so
[Music]
you know and i was i was i think i was
in high school when the twin peaks fire
walk with me movie came out and all of
my friends worked in uh the movie
theater in sherman oaks
so i would go see the movie over and
over again and be the only one in the
theater because nobody else wanted to
see it
just so that i could try to understand
what it was about every time i thought
did you ever get any closer i feel like
every time i saw it like maybe i
understood one more scene than i did the
last time yeah yeah yeah but i saw it
like a dozen times and i still don't
fully know what was going on that's how
i am with muhammad drive i feel like i i
always like the blue box i always like
to think about
what that is and like exactly and i it's
so funny too because i feel like i'm
like i feel like i get it but i think
david lynch would laugh at me if i
explained it
note that david lynch is never going to
explain anything to anybody because it's
just not who he is because i did the
junk it from all in drive and the actors
were like we don't know but it was david
lynch and he told us to do it so we did
no way that's very cool yeah i feel like
that's just how you work with him you
just trust him and you do what he says
and
and that's how it goes it got scary too
because it felt like
it felt like
with um
a mulholland driving at david lynch like
it's it's so much more purposely poetic
you know it's so much it's it's it's
very
much uh intentionally vague and kind of
make it of it what you will and
you know the perfect representation of a
dreamscape
but it feels like with cherry
there is a um
there is there is you know
a a a mystery to it that is kind of like
doled out and you do get to kind of
understand and it's interesting because
like i've seen a lot of people say they
don't after they've seen the series that
they don't know what the title means i i
think i i have a
guess of what the title means but i i
you know it's like people a lot of
people like it's totally random i don't
think it's that random but
i think i think there's some i think
there's some meaning to it but that'll
be that'll be my lynchian mystery
yeah i love it i love especially you
know with somebody like david lynch you
just you know he's not gonna have those
conversations so it's okay and you just
go with it yeah
and that's that's kind of i just i love
this i just i didn't know where it was
going but i'm like i'm just gonna keep
going with it because
i'm all in now whatever else happens
after episode four i'm just all in
and that's it that's we were that's what
we were talking about too is kind of
like hopefully it has that effect that
once you've seen
you know once you kind of get pulled
enough in and i i felt it the first time
i saw the show i felt like i felt it
happened at the end of the pilot like
you know when she goes to confront lou
and lou choke slams her
and then she goes to borrow and throws
up a kitten
and she wants to set his life on fire i
i remember i read that in the script and
i was like oh my god this is amazing and
then i saw it and i was like this might
be a show this is really cool
well thank you for talking to me about
it and uh thank you so much for having
me again it's so great to see you again
yeah you too it just this was this was
wild and i appreciate that very much
about it i'm so i'm so excited that you
appreciate its wildness instead of just
you know because i think a lot of people
will be turned off
by it which i understand and no judgment
i mean like you know it's it's crazy but
you know i do think that for people who
love film and and love you know like
certain genres of film and it's it's a
very exciting thing to see something
different and new and unique and
you know i it's it's the highest praise
to me above being you know like just
like you know kind of a
super crowd please like wow that's
different
yeah and it's hard because with
something like this too like you don't
know if it'll stick the landing properly
which always seems to like the ending of
something like this always seems to be a
little weird where people
maybe start to doubt themselves on the
crazy factor but it went all in and kind
of stayed all in which i
can appreciate i that's a state island
is a good way to say that because i do
think it sticks the landing like i do
think that it has a good and like
satisfying you know end to it so yeah i
totally agree i'm so glad you felt that
way well thank you for talking to me
thank you so much i look forward to the
next one so it's always so great to talk
to you